farah abraham defends letting her
daughter get her septum pierced for her
13th birthday
to sophia it's your mom happy 13th
birthday i can't wait to spend the day
with you a little back story the former
teen mom star's daughter sophia turned
13 earlier this month and to celebrate
the milestone birthday farrah let her
newly minted teen get her septum pierced
naturally they documented the whole
thing on the tick tock account they
share writing that sofia got her 13th
birthday wish
[Music]
quote she did better than her coveted
shot sofia shared the same clip to her
instagram account alongside the caption
quote i am so happy with how it turned
out i am the first person in my family
to get a septum piercing at 13. birthday
wish came true
well all that sparked some major
backlash online and now farrah is
defending her choice in an interview
with tmz admitting she quote wasn't for
it but wanted to make sure her daughter
had the job done safely by a
professional
quote i am doing my best as a parent to
make sure that she is healthy and happy
and i covered those bases she added that
if she wants to get more piercings more
power to her but she doesn't think
she'll ever be down for letting her
little girl get a tattoo she's like a
little star in her own right i'm so
blessed and thankful for my daughter
that i have now this isn't the first
controversy farrah's found herself in
this year she kicked off 2022 with an
arrest after she allegedly slapped a
security guard outside a restaurant in
l.a
so some information is wrong out there
according to police records obtained by
e.t farrah was placed on a citizen's
arrest back in january and later booked
on a charge of misdemeanor assault by
the lapd she was released from custody
less than two hours later and farrah was
quick to address the incident on
instagram even sharing a video of her
arrest
in the caption she called the incident a
conspired attack explaining quote i post
this as no woman or man should ever be
battered abused conspired ganged up on
set up recorded and video sold she added
quote i look forward to my law degree
and i look forward to court justice will
be served as always
for context farrah recently enrolled in
harvard extension school to pursue a law
degree she's expected in court in may
and you never know who will show up
all this comes as farrah makes her
return to reality tv in teen mom family
reunion her first time back with her mtv
fam since parting ways with team mom og
in 2017.
hi good to see you who the
invited pharah
e.t spoke with some of pharah's co-stars
about her return to the franchise here's
what amber portwood had to say about her
co-star's comeback a lot of people said
this so far like everybody should be
there
everybody had the right to be there and
farrah had the right to be there because
she was a part of the original ogs no
matter what i think you guys will be
really really like surprised you know
with how we kind of dealt with a lot of
the drama that they threw at us
you